hey everyone I'm Laura Ingram and this
is the Ingram angle tonight we see rank
corruption that will rock the Public's
trust in four areas at our border at the
doj in the Biden Family itself and even
in the skies above
so for anyone still wondering why tens
of millions of Americans do not trust
Washington well today's dramatic news on
multiple fronts provides critical
answers first in Wilmington Delaware
where Hunter's sweetheart plea deal on
tax and gun charges collapsed into what
I thought was a beautiful pile of rubble
what this means for Hunter Biden is that
he went from a sweetheart Dill a deal to
a real poison pill I mean he this is
going to expose him across the board
then about a hundred miles south on
Capitol Hill we watched his questioning
in two different hearings exposed
government lies dissembling and
concealment again about what's happening
at our border and in the skies above
well we're going to tell you about both
of these stories coming up and later a
disturbing episode involving Senator
Mitch McConnell today that's raising
serious questions about his health
and a string of uh
do you want to say anything else to the
Press
thankfully the senator is said to be
okay but concerns linger
but first we start at a federal court in
Wilmington Delaware where a Brazen move
by Hunter Biden's attorney showed just
how accustomed to special treatment the
president's son really is
now what many of us thought what might
be a fairly routine plea deal acceptance
by judge Mariela norika turned into more
than three hours of negotiations between
the prosecutor and the Biden legal team
now ultimately the intense back and
forth ended with Hunter pleading not
guilty both to the tax and of the gun
charges meaning this is going to drag on
for some time and perhaps well drag the
Biden campaign down with it and yet
another dramatic turn today brought
confirmation that the investigation into
Hunter Biden is apparently continuing
now the doj would not give details about
it but when asked by the judge if this
could potentially bring a foreign
corruption charge prosecutor Leo wise
simply answered yes that's the moment
the agreement completely broke down
well of course right on cue and you were
expecting this right the regime media
hopped into action to dismiss the day's
events I know we've said it over and
over again but all of these claims are
unproven right now and they have no
evidence say it again they have no
evidence that ties this to the president
in the long term it probably doesn't
really mean that much that we had this
wrinkle today
but the truth is on multiple fronts this
is a White House in crisis and as usual
this is all the White House can really
say in response Hunter Biden is a
private citizen and this was a personal
matter for him
as we have said the president the first
lady they love their son and they
support him as he continues to rebuild
his life
all right sorry honey but the pity party
act just does not fly anymore nice try
though
and that private citizen Hunter Biden
rolled up to the hearing about what was
supposedly a personal matter and a
six-car motorcade
we'll hit this developing story from all
angles tonight hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else